[MUSIC]
I've always wondered, why in a nation so
rich are some people so poor?
To me it's always seemed so old fashioned.
Like governments that don't
resemble a democracy or
voting rights that don't include women or
like these wool cardigans.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Things that just shouldn't exist.
[LAUGH]
Growing up,
I often asked myself this question.
Why does poverty still exist?
As a daycare provider,
my mother made enough money for
us to live just above the poverty line.
Despite providing a critical service
to society, she stressed every day
about whether we'd have enough to pay for
rent or buy groceries.
She'd work more and
more hours just to escape being
poor as if it were
a privilege she had to earn.
To me, that just didn't seem right.
The truth about poverty and
inequality in the US is far worse than
my own childhood might have indicated.
In the United States, one out of every
five children live in absolute poverty.
A poverty rate higher than what prevails
in virtually all other rich nations.
Inequality in the US is
the highest it's been since 1928,
right before the Great Depression.
Over the past 35 years,
the real average income of
the top 0.01% has grown
by 322% while that of
the bottom 90% has largely
remained stagnant.
And the American dream of working hard and
finding a way out of
poverty no longer applies.
Increasingly, the greatest predictor
of your future success Is not
your education or your perseverance but
your parents' income and your race.
To make matters worse economists
now say that inequality is so
large that it's had a negative
impact on overall economic growth.
Something we can all care about.
People are poor absolutely,
relatively, and
permanently, and
all at a cost to our nation's growth.
So what can we do?
About two years ago,
after reading everything I could
find to understand poverty and
inequality better and what we can do to
address it, I stumbled across a book.
It's called Utopia for
Realists by Rutger Bregman.
In the book, he chronicles an idea, one so
simple I thought it
couldn't possibly work.
It's an idea that dates back 500 years
to Thomas Moore in his own book,
called Utopia.
Some refer to it as the citizen's
dividend, others call it a basic income.
So what is it?
It's an unconditional monthly cash grant,
enough to pay for your basic needs.
Food, shelter, education, that's it.
It's not a favor, but a right.
As divisive as it might seem it's
actually an idea supported by
individuals across the political spectrum,
from civil rights activists, Dr.
Martin Luther King Jr., who praised it for
its fairness to free market economist,
Milton Friedman, who appreciated
how it instilled freedom of choice.
Now when I tell people that we should
just give free money to everyone,
they usually say, You socialist!
And then they respond with
one of three concerns.
People will spend it on drugs and alcohol.
People will stop working.
We can't afford to pay for it.
So today, I hope to share what I learned
about each of these three concerns, and
hopefully show that a basic income is more
than just an idea, it's a proven idea.
Number one,
people will spend it on drugs and alcohol.
The underlying assumption
with this concern,
stated bluntly, is that there is somehow
something wrong with poor people.
Poor people make poor decisions,
like doing drugs and alcohol,
and that's probably why
they're poor to begin with.
Because of this mindset,
the approach has always been the same.
If we could just teach them,
if we could teach them how to live
life with our values and our culture.
If they would only just listen.
What this mindset fails to recognize are
the drastic effects of living in poverty.
Some poor people make poor
decisions because they're poor.
However, if you change the context,
you can change the actions too.
World Bank researchers found that in
19 different cash transfer programs
across ten different nations, spending
on alcohol and cigarettes went down.
Given hope and a brighter future,
individuals stopped using temptation goods
as a way to cope with
their current situation.
Instead, the extra cash went to pay for
their kids' school fees, to buy medicine,
to repair their homes,
to invest in their small businesses,
to further grow their wealth.
As Bregman concluded,
poverty is not the result
of poor decision making or
lack of moral character.
Poverty is a lack of cash.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Number two, people will stop working.
In the 1970s there's a basic income
experiment in a small town in Canada.
Every family received enough money
to ensure they were lift above
the poverty line.
And for four years all went well,
until a new Canadian government was voted
into power that immediately
ended the experiment.
25 years later, a Canadian professor
found and analyzed these records.
And the results were clear.
School performance went up,
while mental health complaints,
domestic violence incidents and
hospitalization rate all went down.
And no one quit their jobs.
The only ones who worked a little
less were new mothers caring for
their child, and students,
who decided to stay in school longer.
Which brings me to the third and
final concern.
Even if this is all true,
we can't afford to do it.
Actually, we can't afford not to do it.
Poverty is extremely expensive.
The cost of child poverty in the US
is estimated at $500 billion.
In terms of higher healthcare costs,
higher drop out rates, and more crime.
This is an incredible
waste of human potential.
A basic income could be financed
with what's known as a negative
income tax credit.
Which essentially means that your income
is pumped up as soon as you fall below
the poverty line.
Under this scenario,
according to economists best estimates,
for a cost of $175 billion,
less than 1% of GDP, less than
4% of our nation's annual budget,
we could actually eradicate poverty.
As Bregman noted basic income is
like venture capital for the people.
We invest now and
after 10 to 20 years it'll pay for itself.
In terms of lower health care cost,
less crime, and
more productive citizens putting the money
to work and stimulating our economy.
According to current estimates, a basic
income started today would result in
an increase of GDP of 13% by 2025, or
$2.5 trillion.
So when given cash,
people spend less on drugs and
alcohol, work just as much, and
we actually save and generate money.
Well if all this is so obviously
true why haven't we done it already?
The truth is we tried.
In the late 1960's we
piloted a basic income for
close to 9,000 individuals
across seven different states.
And by every measure,
as you might have guessed by now,
the pilot was a success, except for one.
Researchers found that for
those families receiving a basic income,
divorce rates increased by 50%.
Now, this was something politicians of
the time just could not get behind.
A basic income had apparently
given women too much independence.
However, just ten years later
in a reanalysis of the data,
researchers found that this
was a statistical error.
But by that time,
the political moment had passed.
Now we are seeing a re-emergence
of the basic income.
Silicon Valley has taken up the idea based
on fear that robots will one day take
our jobs.
However, while the future is uncertain,
the present is clear.
Poverty exists where and
when it shouldn't.
We need to rid ourselves of
the biases we have about the poor.
We need to acknowledge the wealth,
we have to address the problem and
the potential that we
will unlock if we do so.
We need to redefine our social contract
to say that no one will live in poverty.
But, to do this,
most of all we need the will.
And that will must be founded on
the belief that a life without poverty
should not be a privilege
you have to earn but
a right that we all deserve.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]